eu fisheries ministers hope to reach a
political agreement on quotas for
catches of certain fish species in the
baltic sea for next year when they meet
in luxembourg on october 17.
the european commission is proposing
maximum quantities for specific kinds of
fish including herring cod salmon and
spratt taking into account the latest
scientific advice and reports by key
fisheries and maritime organizations
in the case of cod quotas are
established in line with a specific
long-term plan to ensure that stocks in
the baltic sea are not depleted
the plan includes limits for the number
of days at sea authorized for this kind
of fishing
the catch limits data is supposed to be
made available to fishermen in the
baltic by the 1st of january next year
the ministers will also hold an exchange
of views on the annual consultations
between the eu and norway on the
management of shared fish stocks such as
those in the north sea and skagerek
size of annual catch quantities on seven
species including cod haddock herring
whiting and shrimp are jointly agreed
between the two at the moment
the ministers will also hold an exchange
of views ahead of the annual meeting of
the international commission for the
conservation of atlantic tunas which
will take place from the 18th to the
25th of november in south africa
the organization's work has an impact on
the management of among other species
bluefin tuna in the atlantic and the
mediterranean and this has important
implications for the fishing industry in
the eu and the preservation of stocks